hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's eine gesundes mittagessen
extra findet morath und zwar habe ich
vor ein paar wochen einen kochkurs
gegeben
und da haben wir zusammen mit den
teilnehmern hähnchenbrustfilets und
offen gemüse gemacht und das möchte ich
heute in meinem video vorstellen
ich werde zuerst einmal das offen gemüse
vorbereiten und später gibt es dann das
hinter mir dazu und dann ist alles
innerhalb von etwa 35 40 45 minuten
fertig und verzehr bereit
ich hab da vorne zu über die zutaten für
das offen gemüse ich brauche dafür vier
bis fünf kartoffeln eine grüne paprika
eine rote paprika zwei rote zwiebeln
eine aubergine eine zucchini und 200
gramm champignons 200 gramm
cocktailtomaten und dann brauche ich
noch ein paar gewürze und zwar zwei
teelöffel oregano zwei teelöffel minze
zwei teelöffel rosmarin etwas salz und
pfeffer und zwei esslöffel olivenöl und
ich habe sie die kartoffeln bereits
gewaschen und werde jetzt auch mit der
schale direkt zu bereiten und zwar
müssen jetzt die kartoffel erst einmal
kurz vor gegart werden und dann kann das
restliche gemüse mit dazu dann ist
nämlich alles gleichzeitig fertig das
heißt wenn alles gleich groß ist dann
ist auch gleichzeitig gar so alles muss
unterschiedlich groß sein denn jedes
gemüse hat eine unterschiedliche garzeit
natürlich gemüse schneiden wie die
garzeit ist genau deswegen kommen jetzt
erst die kartoffeln dran
die schneide ich jetzt in so kleine
ecken
also erstmal halbieren und die
kartoffeln die brauchen am längsten
genau deswegen kommt jetzt auch ganz
kurz vorher in den backofen
den habe ich auch bereits auf 200 grad
ober unterhitze vorgeheizt
die kartoffeln gebe ich jetzt schon mal
in eine auflaufform und setzt den
backofen sommer für zehn minuten vor
banken und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
schon als lästig gemüse
was ich vorhin noch vergessen habt zu
erwähnen ist natürlich die knoblauchzehe
ich habe es hier eine große kino braucht
es eine chinesische morath sagt er steht
man dazu aber ihr könnt euch auch zwei
kleine knoblauchzehe die schneide ich
jetzt in dünne scheiben und das
restliche gemüse habe ich so geschnitten
also die zwiebel in so halb bringe die
sind fünf millimeter dick die paprika
habe ich in 1 cm dicke streifen
geschnitten die zucchini in etwa ein
zentimeter dicke scheiben und die
champignons nur halbiert ich möchte dass
die gerne etwas groß bleiben und die
auberginen würfe die sind etwa 1 bis 2
cm groß jetzt kann ich schon mal die
marinade zubereiten und zwar brauche ich
dafür zwei esslöffel öl und gibt da
jetzt noch die grenze mit rein jeweils
zwei teelöffel
und salz gebe ich nur einen teelöffel
betreiben ich streue es auch schon mal
direkt salz auf die kartoffeln
da die da jetzt unten drin liegen und
wird direkt mit pfeffer und da kommt
jetzt direkte restliche gemüse mit drauf
das fragen sich alle wie krieg dich
seine das ganze gehäuse in gefahr
das kriegst du hin
und jetzt kommt da die gewürzmischung
noch mit drauf und es für mich spannend
in händen
wenn ich das jetzt nicht ganz so
kalorienarm haben möchte dann geht es
einfach noch ein bisschen olivenöl mehr
dazu das hat einen besseren geschmack
auf jeden fall
und jetzt kommt das offen gemüse wieder
in den ofen für etwa 25 minuten und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal das
hähnchen vorbereiten
für das hinziehen post filet brauche ich
60 gramm getrocknete tomaten die sind
bereits eingelegt 4s müssen frischkäse
vier hähnchenbrustfilets 200 milliliter
wasser und zwei teelöffel mail etwas
salz und pfeffer und dann brauche ich
noch jeweils zwei teelöffel rosmarin
süßes paprikapulver und oregano und zwei
esslöffel olivenöl
jetzt werde ich zuerst mal die füllung
vorbereiten und zwar wenn die
hähnchenbrustfilets nämlich gefüllt mit
frischkäse und tomate und falls ihr
jetzt keine getrockneten tomaten in öl
eingelegt findet könnt ihr auch ganz
normale getrocknete tomaten nehmen
und da geht nämlich auch welche ohne öl
und die muss man vorher am besten einmal
nur kurz mit heißem wasser übergießen
dann werden sie auch schön weich die hat
jetzt ein bisschen klein
die tomaten gwc direkt mit rein und die
getrockneten tomaten die in öl eingelegt
sind diese immer so ein bisschen
aromatischer weil er in dem öl auch ganz
viele gewürze mit dabei sind jetzt für
rührig die mit dem frischkäse fertig und
ich kann die hähnchenbrust für dieses
nehmen und macht die erstmals sauber und
zwar nehme ich da immer dieses innen
viele erstmal raus kann man extra an
warten jetzt schneide ich hier oben
direkt eine tasche ein kam es mir sehr
vorsichtig arbeiten dann habe ich
nämlich hier so eine öffnung
und jetzt kann ich mit einem kleinen
teelöffel der füllung hier vorne rein
film
kommen zwei esslöffel olivenöl in einer
pfanne wunsch da werden die putenbrust
stücken jetzt ganz scharf angebraten
alles live von allen seiten angebraten
ist kommt es noch ein bisschen mehl
darüber später dafür dass die quote
etwas gebunden werden das fahrzeug mit
und dann läuft das ganze mit warmem
wasser ab
es gibt auch direkt die gewürze mit rein
damit
und jetzt muss ich das alles nur noch
mit salz und pfeffer würzen dann auf
mittlere stufe stellen und dann kann das
etwa 10 minuten garen
fünf minuten vor ende der garzeit kommen
jetzt auch die tomaten mit rein
und zwar werden die dann nicht ganz
weich sondern platz man einfach nur ein
bisschen auf fertig ja ich freue mich
mal dass es mal keine torte isst muss
ich sagen ja gesunde woche hallo ich
gesagt ich freue mich drauf ist auch
noch gesundes gemüse weglassen nur das
fleisch ist nein spaß kommt ich weiß es
gut schmeckt ja das schmeckt richtig gut
jetzt gebe ich dir da noch so 13
genau kein bisschen genau herr soße
könnte man natürlich jetzt noch ein
bisschen dicker machen
das heißt ihr bildet jetzt das fleisch
herausnehmen und noch ein bisschen an
dicken mit mehl aber ich finds nicht mit
sorgt abschluss probieren was der
nächsten hat ja hat können wir ja 182
grad ich probiere es jetzt nicht oder
doch ich probiere es war ganz vorsichtig
ich bin ja wohl der pilze fan hier
probiert das genial
ich finde so offen gemüse ist echt immer
mal schnell gemacht wo hat es so etwas
gefüllt
genial
mein gott richtig genial hier
schmeckt lecker wie genial wirklich
genial
also ich vor allem dass du auch mal
gemüse isst was das war gemüse nein ich
bin jetzt ein super tolles rezept was
man sehr gut mahl zubereiten kann vor
allem finde ich oben gerichte immer
genial weil man sein free and open
steckt unter ofen erledigt einfach die
ganze arbeit als ihr dieses rezept nach
machen wollt geht aufs tennis - roger
stets noch mal ganz genau warten
ach so hier habe ich kein auberginen
fällen aber hier schmecken sie wirklich
klasse ich finde da verbindet sich an
alle erhoben so ein bisschen und mit nur
zu zeigen
das ist also richtig genial auch das
fleisch mit den tomaten es ist ein traum
und genial wirklich ich finds halt immer
so toll wenn die tomaten grad so
aufplatzen und dann sind sie genau
richtig
oder wenn man natürlich frische gewisse
tat kann man auch frische pizza zu
frischen kräutern rosmarinzweig und so
weiter vor etlichen kann natürlich auch
das gemüse also das gemüse weglassen was
man nicht möchte und das zu nehmen was
man möchte also ganz variable oder
fleisch so gigantisch schmeckt so lecker
aufhören ich viel spaß beim nachkochen
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
bis basel das fleisch kenia die
jeweilige von mir mein profil